«Статус кандидата на вступ до ЄС -
не пропуск без контролю» - розмова з фон дер Ляєн
Три місяці загарбницької війни Росії проти України.
Коли закінчиться війна?
Невимовні страждання. Витік даних підтверджує
табори масового інтернування уйгурів
В ефірі «heute journal» з
Гайнцом Вольфом і Марієттою Сломкою.
Добрий вечір.
Минуло три місяці від початку війни в Україні
та краху світоглядного усталеного порядку в Німеччині.
Як відомо, дехто був менш здивований тим,
що загарбницькі амбіції Володимира Путіна візьмуть
гору і він наважиться напасти на сусідню країну.
На цьому кривавому шляху Путіна не зупиняють
десятки тисяч загиблих, серед них і російських солдатів.
За ці три місяці сталося багато.
Зокрема те, чого Путін точно не очікував:
європейці міцно об'єднали зусилля з американцями,
а українці мужньо взялися за зброю.
Наразі основні бойові дії зосереджено
на Донбасі, на Сході України.
Наш репортер Геннер Гебештрайт далі.
У Дніпрі бур'янам не лишають жодного шансу,
навіть якщо в країні вже 90 днів триває війна,
а на іншому березі видніється дим:
російські ракетні обстріли дедалі ближчають.
До повсякденного життя містян вже увійшло
зведення імпровізованих захисних барикад та
протитанкових перешкод, а також щоденна
відправка гуманітарної допомоги на передову.
Часом виявляється надзвичайна вигадливість.
Ось саморобний перископ для спостережень з укриттів.
Ми виготовили основу цього перископу
за допомогою 3D-принтеру.
Потім прикріпили трубу та 2 дзеркала.
До війни Марія навчалася музиці,
грала на скрипці та фортепіано.
Замість підготовки до академконцерту,
Марія вже 3 місяці допомагає українським солдатам.
За офіційними даними від української сторони,
щодня на Донбасі гине понад 100 бійців.
Найближчі тижні війни будуть складними.
І ми повинні це усвідомлювати.
Але в нас немає жодної альтернативи,
крім як боротися.
Росія також не планує відступати.
Глянцеві кадри, оприлюднені
Міністерством оборони РФ,
демонструють «військову перевагу» Росії,
однак британські спецслужби
повідомляють про загибель
близько 30 тисяч російських солдатів.
Попри військовий хаос цей чоловік
доклав максимум зусиль,
щоб запобігти новій ядерній катастрофі в Україні.
Озброєні солдати й танки
на Чорнобильській АЕС
добряче налякали
інженера з безпеки на ЧАЕС Валерія Семенова.
Перш ніж відступити після 35-денної облоги ЧАЕС,
російські військові встигли пограбувати адмінофіси.
Близько 45 хв вони згрібали усе, що
потрапляло під руку,
навіть особисті речі персоналу.
Вони повикидали нові запасні колеса
зі своїх вантажівок, щоб звільнити місце для награбованого.
Напад Росії на Україну приніс страшні
страждання цивільному населенню.
За даними ООН, наразі загинуло
майже 4000 мирних жителів.
Усі ці жахіття сприяють пробудженню
національної свідомості українців.
Після 3 місяців війни Марія
зайняла чітку проукраїнську позицію,
незважаючи на своє російське коріння.
Відносини з родиною змінилися.
Так, спочатку було важко.
Ми самі не знали, що насправді відбувається,
багато сперечалися з цього приводу.
У Дніпрі люди намагаються повертатися
до нормального життя.
Дніпряни сподіваються, що війна не перетне Дніпра.
Звісно ж, війна стала головною темою
Всесвітнього економічного форуму в Давосі.
Серед поважних гостей цьогорічного форуму
Президентка Європейської комісії
Урсула фон дер Ляєн.
Нам вдалося поспілкуватися з
пані фон дер Ляєн,
проте спершу - сюжет Сюзанни Біденкопф.
Ожеледицю змінили яскраві квіти.
Весняний девіз у Давосі: «рухайтеся».
Піша хода корисна для здоров'я і клімату,
та й загалом у світі, повному протиріч,
приємно керувати принаймні власними кроками.
Війна в Україні та її наслідки - головна тема
для обговорень, що задає тон усій зустрічі.
Чого насправді варті наші цінності та наш бізнес?
Це питання прозвучало з вуст чоловіка, який завжди
виступав за глобалізацію економіки.
Генсек НАТО Єнс Столтенберг
попереджає про наслідки залежності
від авторитарних режимів,
і йдеться не лише про енергетичні питання.
Треба визнати, що наші економічні рішення
мають безпосередній вплив на нашу безпеку.
Свобода важливіша, ніж вільна торгівля.
Захист наших цінностей
важливіший за прибуток.
Президентка Європейської комісії
Урсула фон дер Ляєн
вже розмірковує про відбудову
повоєнної України.
Збір коштів повинен відбуватися
системно та скоординовано.
Це завдання вона пропонує довірити
європейській платформі.
Платформа відкрита для внесків з усього світу.
Кожна країна, якій не байдуже майбутнє України,
може долучитися до нашої ініціативи.
Міжнародні фінансові установи
і приватні особи.
Ми маємо об'єднати наші зусилля.
Кожен може долучитися до нашої команди.
Кожен?
Міністр фінансів Німеччини не зовсім поділяє
думку пані фон дер Ляєн.
Він не вважає спільні європейські борги
хорошою ідеєю.
Спільний інструмент для відбудови, що фінансується
за рахунок боргових зобов'язань
та надходить у вигляді гранту,
тобто «ЄС наступного покоління»,
виключається з нашої регуляторної політики.
Керівник енергетичної компанії Bayer
повідомив, що вже вживає
конкретних заходів задля допомоги Україні.
У короткостроковій перспективі йдеться
про підтримку родин 700 наших співробітників в Україні.
Ми забезпечуємо їх роботою
та допомагаємо з нагальними проблемами.
Наступний крок полягає у відбудові та розбудові
нашої інфраструктури в Україні,
яка наразі суттєво пошкоджена.
Для цього ми готові
зробити необхідні інвестиції.
Увечері в Давосі відбувся
Концерт солідарності з Україною
з надією на те, що одного дня
світло таки переможе темряву.
З нами на прямому зв'язку з Давосу
пані президентка Європейської комісії.
Доброго вечора, пані фон дер Ляєн.
Доброго вечора, пані Сломка.
Учора ми розмовляли з
міністром економіки Німеччини Робертом Габеком.
Він був дуже оптимістично налаштований
щодо нафтового ембарго.
Сказав, що за кілька днів
очікує на справжній прорив.
Ви поділяєте його оптимізм?
Ми наполегливо працюємо для
впровадження нафтового ембарго.
Кілька країн-учасниць ЄС
мають певні технічні проблеми,
зокрема відсутність виходу до моря.
Таким чином, ці країни не можуть отримувати
нафту морським шляхом.
Ми вже працюємо над вирішенням цієї проблеми,
зокрема розглядаємо можливість заміни морського
газопроводу на сухопутний.
Також плануємо модернізацію або переоснащення
нафтопереробних заводів.
Ми збільшуємо інвестиції у
відновлювані джерела енергії.
Щодо усіх цих кроків наразі тривають обговорення.
Ви згадували про технічні проблеми,
але хіба справа лише в цьому?
Здається, міністру закордонних справ Литви
вже уривається терпець після перемовин з Угорщиною.
Цитую: «Угорщина тримає нас як заручників».
Що насправді заважає пану Орбану,
йдеться лише про технічні проблеми?
Угорщина - одна з країн-учасниць ЄС,
про які Ви щойно згадували, описуючи
труднощі із запровадженням нафтового ембарго.
Безсумнівно, ми маємо певні труднощі з Угорщиною.
Тривають дискусії
стосовно обсягу інвестицій.
Важливо, щоб інші 26 країн-учасниць ЄС бачили,
що цей розподіл відбувається справедливо.
Ми хочемо інвестувати у
відновлювані джерела енергії,
щоб у майбутньому мати заміну енергоресурсам,
які раніше купували в Росії.
Але цей процес має
відбуватися справедливо для усіх нас.
Важливою темою також є
повоєнна відбудова України.
Наразі жорстока та кровопролитна війна триває.
Але українці також починають думати
про повоєнну відбудову країни.
Міністр фінансів Німеччини Крістіан Лінднер
чітко дав зрозуміти, що відбудова України важлива,
проте він відхиляє ідею про спільний борг ЄС
дляфінансування грантів Україні.
Що Ви скажете з цього приводу?
Я запропонувала створити платформу,
яка б об'єднала «під одним дахом» зусилля,
яких вже докладають у всьому світі.
Діяльність цієї платформи координувалася б
Україною та Європейською комісією.
Адже ми прагнемо не просто інвестувати,
хоч це теж важливий пункт нашої програми, але й
впроваджувати важливі для України реформи.
Адміністративна реформа та подолання корупції
є запоруками успішного розвитку
економіки України.
Тому платформа має стати майданчиком
для об'єднання:
Організація економічного співробітництва
та розвитку, Світовий банк, Європейський союз
та наші американські партнери - усі мають
погодитися з тим, що відбудова України
полягає не лише в інвестиціях,
а й у важливих реформах.
Це також відкриває Україні шлях
у Європейський Союз.
Добре, що Ви торкнулися цієї теми.
Про неї - наступне питання.
Як голова Єврокомісії
Ви оголосите у червні надання Україні
статусу кандидата в ЄС?
Ми все ще в процесі аналізу.
Мені важливо ще раз підкреслити
щодо статусу країни-кандидата:
це не пропуск без контролю.
І тут немає поступок.
У процесі вступу країна
повинна виконати вимоги стандартів,
які виконуємо ми всі в ЄС:
вимоги економічних, політичних, правових стандартів...
Але це дуже залежить від того,
наскільки швидко й активно діє країна.
Є приклади країн,
які пройшли процедуру вступу за 2-3 роки.
Як-от Словаччина, яка швидко об'єднала усі зусилля в країні
і зробила великі кроки вперед.
Пані фон дер Ляєн,
йдеться поки що лише про статус країни-кандидата.
Він ще нічого не говорить
про терміни набуття членства.
Це також політичний жест.
Ви виступали за те,
щоб реалізувати цю надію українців.
Могли б Ви конкретніше сказати,
чи дотримуєтеся цієї позиції?
Ви допомагали українцям
заповнити ці товсті опитувальники,
які потрібні для подання заявки.
Правильно, і цей процес завершиться після аналізу.
На якому етапі країна?
Що я можу порекомендувати?
І передусім,
чому я це рекомендую?
Це буде відомо приблизно в середині червня.
Довго чекати не доведеться.
Але мені важливо наголосити:
процес може бути швидким, як-от зі Словаччиною.
Водночас країна-кандидат
може чекати роками і десятиліттями,
якщо рухається повільно.
Це залежить від якості прогресу
і за це відповідає країна.
Ми справді хочемо дати Україні шанс
рухатися вперед.
Важливою темою в Давосі був експорт пшениці,
який блокує Росія.
Неможливість вивезти з України зерно,
яке заблоковане в портах.
Чи вже є конкретне рішення?
Звісно, західні держави не почнуть
бомбити Одесу, щоб знищити російські позиції.
Має бути інше рішення.
Чи є надія,
що вдасться вивезти пшеницю з України?
Ситуація драматична.
20 млн тонн пшениці зараз застрягли в Україні.
Росія систематично бомбить зерносховища.
Катастрофічна ситуація, бо ця пшениця потрібна світу,
особливо найбіднішим країнам.
Ми зараз намагаємося
вивезти пшеницю іншими шляхами.
Вантажівками, потягами.
Це, звісно, не так ефективно, як морем.
Дехто намагається домовитися з Росією,
чи не було б рішенням
відкрити коридори у Чорному морі.
І це добре.
Переговори лише почалися,
але ми повинні вести їх.
Потрібно уникнути сильного голоду у країнах,
які найбільше постраждали,
які є найбільш чутливими і вразливими.
Пані фон дер Ляєн, дякую за розмову.
Дякую Вам.
Те, що Україна не може експортувати пшеницю,
спричиняє серйозні проблеми.
Проте теоретично нестачу
можна було б компенсувати
за участі інших країн.
Певні надії покладали на Індію,
яка теж є великим виробником зерна.
Індійці були зацікавлені в тому,
щоб завоювати нові ринки.
Але все різко змінилося, відколи стало зрозуміло,
що цьогоріч Індія збере значно менше врожаю.
Країна страждає від рекордної спеки та посухи.
Ключове слово - зміна клімату.
До того ж зростають ціни, що відчутно і в Індії.
Тож уряд ввів заборону на експорт пшениці,
побоюючись, що інакше їжі бракуватиме у самій країні.
Детальніше - Нормен Оденталь.
Сапна — одна із десятків мільйонів
найбідніших жителів Індії,
яким постійно загрожує голод.
Лише державні продовольчі програми
допомагають їм вижити.
Щомісяця Сапна безкоштовно отримує пшеницю.
В умовах пандемії раціон збільшився до 8 кг на людину.
Вдома вона пече хліб чапаті,
їжу для всієї родини.
Нам потрібне дешеве зерно.
Якби його не було, я не знаю, як годувала б дітей.
Вони голодували б.
1,3 млрд осіб живуть в Індії.
Всі повинні їсти, всім потрібен хліб,
всім потрібна пшениця,
тож сільське господарство в Індії важливе.
Фермери як Рамгопал годують країну.
У мене є 5 гектарів полів, де я вирощую пшеницю,
крім цього лише кілька корів.
Але земля хороша.
У нас багаті врожаї, тільки не цього року.
Спека все зіпсувала.
Голі поля, врожай вже зібрали. Надто рано.
Фермери були змушені зібрати пшеницю,
доки вона повністю не висохла.
Тривала спека не залишила Рамгопалу вибору.
Погляньте, ось це найбільші зерна.
В інші роки їх вважали б найгіршої якості.
Зараз це найкраще, що я маю.
Через спеку мої поля принесли на 50% менше врожаю.
Втрати всюди.
Практично все зібране зерно
звозять сюди, у державні сховища.
Індія робить запаси.
У країні, де й так багато хто голодує,
неврожай може значно погіршити ситуацію.
Тому держава каже:
Пшениця лишиться в країні - заборона на експорт.
Це правильно,
що ми більше не експортуємо пшеницю.
Запасів може не вистачити.
Тоді ми самі нічого не матимемо
і будемо змушені купувати пшеницю за кордоном.
Кілька тижнів тому
уряд голосно озвучував інші плани:
Індія годуватиме світ, замінивши Україну,
де масштабне вирощування пшениці
постраждало від війни.
Але потім настала спека і уряд відступив від своїх слів.
Попереду важливі вибори.
Ми вже побачили, що продовольча програма
може гарантувати багато голосів бідних жителів,
тому керівній партії потрібні заповнені зерносховища.
Це погано,
бо руйнує довіру світу до Індії.
Винятки залишаються можливими
і отримують потрібну
для маркетингових цілей інсценізацію.
Тут 2000 тонн пшениці урочисто і з розмахом
відправляють в Афганістан.
Голод - це глобальне явище.
Індія не хоче, щоб їй закидали те,
що у цій боротьбі вона думає тільки про себе.
Детальніше цю тему розгляне Ґундула Ґаузе
у програмі «heute journal up:date»
з керівником Всесвітньої продовольчої програми ООН
від Німеччини.
Далі Гайнц Вольф з новинами.
Почастішали випадки мавпячої віспи.
У Європі їх понад 100,
у Німеччині підтвердили мінімум 8.
Інститут Роберта Коха рекомендує ізолювати хворих
принаймні на 21 день,
щоб взяти під контроль спалах захворювання.
Міністр охорони здоров'я Німеччини Лаутербах
наголосив, що це не початок нової пандемії,
але до мавпячої віспи потрібно ставитися серйозно.
Це вірусне захворювання виникає
зазвичай у Західній та Центральній Африці
і дуже рідко в інших місцях,
тож нинішні спалахи незвичні.
Постійна комісія з вакцинації (STIKO)рекомендує
вакцинувати від коронавірусу
дітей віком від 5 до 11 років.
Тепер рекомендація стосується
не лише тих, хто має супутні захворювання,
а й усіх дітей цього віку.
Це запобіжний захід,
адже восени та взимку очікують зростання
захворюваності на коронавірус.
У землях Шлезвіґ-Гольштейн
та Північний Рейн-Вестфалія
сьогодні відбулися «чорно-зелені» переговори
щодо можливості
формування коаліційного уряду.
У Північному Рейні-Вестфалії
на перший раунд переговорів
прийшли прем'єрміністр Вюст від CDU
і лідерка партії Зелених Нойбаур зі своїми делегаціями.
У Шлезвіґ-Гольштейні просунулися далі.
Після переговорів
між прем'єрміністром від CDU Ґюнтером
та головними кандидатками
від партії Зелених Гайнольд і Туре
Зелені вирішили вступити у переговори про коаліцію.
Сьогодні у комітеті Бундестагу
з контролю за проведенням виборів
йшлося про вибори,
що відбулися у вересні минулого року.
Точніше про звинувачення
у помилках на виборчих дільницях Берліну.
Голова виборчої комісії Тіль говорив
про часткове повторне голосування.
За словами голови комітету,
на рішення щодо цієї справи
до літніх канікул парламенту
не варто розраховувати.
Ексканцлер Шредер заявив, що відхилив пропозицію
російського держконцерну «Газпром»
увійти до ради директорів.
До того ж вже давно.
Так він відреагував на те,
що компанія ще раз підтвердила його кандидатуру.
Минулого тижня Шредер пішов
з ради директорів «Роснєфті»,
іншого російського енергетичного концерну.
Це сталося після звинувачень
у тісних зв'язках з Росією.
Прем'єрміністр Угорщини Орбан
оголосив надзвичайний стан через війну в Україні.
За словами Орбана, це допоможе захистити Угорщину
від економічних потрясінь,
надасть урядові простір для маневру
та можливість негайно реагувати.
Надзвичайний стан дозволяє урядові
приймати закони на основі указів без згоди парламенту.
Дія надзвичайного стану в Угорщині,
пов'язаного з пандемією коронавірусу,
закінчується в кінці цього місяця.
На засіданні очільників урядів Японії, Австралії,
Індії та США президент Байден назвав
напад Росії на Україну
«глобальною проблемою».
У Токіо Байден закликав
до сильнішої підтримки для України.
Запобігання подібному конфлікту в
Індо-Тихоокеанському регіоні
є загальновизнаною метою країн-учасниць
чотиристороннього діалогу з безпеки (QUAD).
Без прямої згадки про Китай
у спільній заяві йдеться
про відмову від заходів
одностороннього спрямування,
які посилюють напруженість у регіоні.
Зрештою, якщо Китай колись нападе на Тайвань,
багато хто не здивується,
що Народна Республіка є агресивною державою
не тільки на власній території.
Підхід «зміни через торгівлю» не спрацював і там.
Усвідомлення цього поширюється на Заході
досить повільно.
Майже філософське твердження сьогодні оголосив
Генсек НАТО Єнс Столтенберг у Давосі:
«Свобода важливіша, ніж вільна торгівля».
В регіоні Сіньцзян, на Північному Заході Китаю,
є давно відомий табір для інтернованих,
де утримують ﻿представників
мусульманської меншини уйгурів.
Але через витік секретних документів міжнародні ЗМІ,
як-от BBC та Der Spiegel,
зараз вперше змогли оприлюднити
багато матеріалів про ці табори,
попередньо перевіривши усі документи.
Ульф Роллер з репортажем.
Вони дивляться на нас
і не дають нам відвести погляд.
В'язнів таборів перевиховання
віднині можна побачити в обличчя.
Вони за ґратами через свою віру.
За вивчення релігійних писань - 34 роки покарання.
Про це свідчать ці документи.
Безсумнівно, дані дійсно доводять
тюремну природу цих таборів перевиховання.
В документах точно зазначено,
як саме охороняється табір,
яку зброю застосовує поліція.
Адріан Ценц отримав дані анонімно.
Він роками займається
дослідженнями долі уйгурів.
Є жахливі світлини, на яких видно,
як жорстоко уряд Китаю пригноблює уйгурів.
Світлини 2018 року з табору перевиховання в Сіньцзяні.
Вони документують масове ув'язнення та
культурне знищення меншини мусульман-уйгурів.
Є підтвердження, що накази надходять
від самого президента Сі Цзіньпіня.
Сам Сі наказує найняти більше поліцейських,
більше наглядачів для таборів та в'язниць.
У Сіньцзяні нараховують понад 300 таборів.
За даними, мільйон осіб,
які належать до мусульманських меншин,
були інтерновані Китаєм до таборів останніми роками.
Документи надали жертвам обличчя.
Міжнародна спільнота має моральний обов'язок
зупинити цей геноцид.
Більше немає причин про це мовчати,
оскільки є нові докази.
У 2021 році ми самі відвідали Сіньцзян.
Кашгар - оплот уйгурів.
Поліція - на кожному розі.
Ми зустріли трьох дівчат.
Побіжно вони розповідають нам про
табори перевиховання,
не називаючи їх прямо.
Це місце для навчання.
Там багато людей.
Ось чому деякі уйгури кажуть, що вони - не вільні.
У деяких з нас туди забирали і маму, і тата.
Сьогодні пані комісар ООН з прав людини
зустрілась із міністром закордонних справ Китаю.
Вона ще не дала коментар щодо звинувачень.
Натомість Пекін стверджує, що це брехня.
Це ще одна спроба
наклепу з-поміж інших у антикитайській кампанії.
Завжди одне й те ж.
Але ця брехня не введе світ в оману.
Зараз міністерка закордонних справ Німеччини
Бербок вимагає роз'яснень.
Для мене важливо почути
роз'яснення і позицію Китаю
щодо цих давно відомих звинувачень.
Китай не хоче, аби світ бачив ці світлини.
Китай хоче,
щоб ми відвернули погляд в інший бік.
Поки ми проводили зйомку документів,
вебсторінка зникла.
Є підозра, що це - справа рук Китаю.
А зараз Гайнц з новинами економіки.
У Німеччині дедалі більше не вистачає
кваліфікованих працівників на підприємствах.
За квітневими даними
державного банку розвитку KfW,
нестача кваліфікованих працівників
досягла нового піку.
Валері Галлер, що це означає?
Які наслідки має нестача
кваліфікованих працівників?
Це має серйозні наслідки.
Звісно, нестача кваліфікованих працівників
гальмує роботу окремих підприємств,
замовлення не виконуються,
але вона загрожує також великим проєктам:
змінам у енергетичній і
транспортній політиці, дигіталізації,
покращенні системи медичного догляду,
масштабному житловому будівництву.
На думку дослідників економіки,
усього цього можна буде досягти за умови,
якщо в країну прибуватиме більше
кваліфікованих працівників
і не лише ті, хто має освітній ступінь.
У квітні дефіцит кваліфікованих працівників
встановив новий рекорд.
«Лідером» залишається сфера обслуговування,
зокрема гастрономія і туризм.
Дуже страждає переробна промисловість,
будівництво та торгівля.
Якщо підсумовувати: майже половина
підприємств, які взяли участь в опитуванні,
скаржаться на нестачу спеціалістів.
Це також відчутно і в найбільшому аеропорту Німеччини.
Хоча компанія наймає людей,
працівників все одно не вистачає.
У результаті, зокрема довгий час очікування
для пасажирів.
Голова ради директорів Fraport Штефан Шульте
вибачався за незручності на загальних зборах.
Рейси доводиться відкладати або ж відміняти.
Занадто мало працівників і в авіакомпаніях.
Спілка пілотів «Cockpit»
очікує масові скасування рейсів цього літа.
Причин дефіциту кваліфікованих кадрів багато.
Менше випускників шкіл, демографічні зміни.
На думку експертів економіки,
імміграція та підвищення престижу
професійної підготовки
допоможуть вирішити цю проблему.
Валері Галлер, дуже дякую.
Про Бундеслігу та двох нових тренерів:
у ФК «Вольфсбург» новим тренером став Ніко Ковач,
а ФК «Гоффенгайм» тренуватиме Андре Брайтенрайтер.
На чемпіонаті світу з хокею збірна Німеччини
програла Швейцарії з рахунком 3:4.
Удар Маттіаса Плахти, який зрівняв рахунок 3:3,
врятував Німеччину до серії буллітів.
Булліт Дам'єна Ріи став
вирішальним для перемоги Швейцарії.
Команда Німеччини посіла друге місце у групі
і післязавтра зустрінеться у чвертьфіналі
з багаторазовим чемпіоном світу - Чехією,
яка увечері поступилася господарям турніру -
команді з Фінляндії.
Це був «heute journal».
За мить буде веселіше разом із випуском «Anstalt».
О 00:45 «heute journal up:date» з Ґундулою Ґаузе.
До завтра, до зустрічі.
Ласкаво просимо до перегляду прогнозу погоди.
Як показує графік температур Берліну,
у п'ятницю, суботу, неділю
знову стане значно прохолодніше.
Температура знизиться від 20° до 15°.
Вночі температура переважно нижче 10°.
Через вітер із заходу погода лишається мінливою.
Сьогодні ввечері температура впаде і
становитиме від 6° до 12°.
У регіоні Айфель також частково холоднішатиме.
Вночі переважно без опадів.
Між Баварським лісом та Альпами знову дощитиме.
З вечора вівторка вже випали опади.
Завтра на південному сході буде хмарно.
Потім дощ перейде у
короткочасні зливи та поступово припиниться.
Короткочасні зливи та грози
на узбережжях морів,
передусім по обіді посилиться
південно-західний вітер.
Але у полосі від південного заходу до Бранденбурга
вранці сухо та сонячно.
Завтра температура тут
від 20° до 24°.
Далі холоднішатиме,
температура від 16° до 20°.
Такий температурний діапазон
і на Вознесіння - від 16° до 24°.
На півдні помірно та без опадів,
на півночі сильна хмарність, знову зливи та вітер
зі шквалами із заходу.
В п'ятницю і суботу мінлива та вітряна погода.
Стане трохи прохолодніше:
в суботу температура від 14° до 20°.
Гарного тижня. До зустрічі.